good
good long day at
work long day at work you just
finished oh yeah nice nice nice nice for
sure what do you want to start off with
us
today all right all right every
[Laughter]
okay all right every listen everyy
listen I'm listening
all right all right what do you mean by
Muslim why do you play these word games
Avery why do you play these [__] word
games language language language excuse
the language excuse the
language
um what do you mean by Muslim why do you
play these word games well you guys say
he's a Muslim so whatever you guys mean
by it yeah but you know what we mean
when he say he's a Muslim you know what
we mean by that what do you
mean we it's uh it means that he
submitted his will to God which God you
know what
we oh for God's sake oh for excuse me
blasphemy it's okay you can say you can
say for S why you keep doing this why do
you keep doing this Avery you know what
we mean by it because I I want I want I
want you guys to start thinking about
what you actually
say your issue is you're you um which
which gu you can f you can fate the term
Muslim
with the theological
foundations and of Islam and the Quran
and everything like that why why do you
conflate it all together rather than
understanding that it can be a term
applied to Historic prophets in time it
doesn't have to be let me let me let me
ask okay let me ask can someone be
considered a
Muslim and they go against the Islam
tenants uh you know the the core
doctrines of Islam can someone be a
Muslim and go against the core doctrines
of
Islam openly go against them no okay so
that's why because being a Muslim is
intrinsically tied to Islamic core
Doctrine and so if you're outside of
that you're not a
muslim okay so prove okay so where does
Jesus Christ go outside of that well you
you have to show me that he's in line
with it you have to show me that he in
his beliefs and his teachings and and
his practices aligned with Islamic
Doctrine that's what you have to show me
that's why I say prove that he was a
Muslim yeah well I'm making the claim
that according to our histography he is
in line with according to your what so
I'm sorry our his our histography
histography yeah according to according
to to our sourc source he is in line
with it so now it's not it's not a
problem of negation or a claim you can
now just uh provide the opposite say
this no it's a claim you're saying
according to my source which is I would
assume is the Quran
right of course right so the Quran that
comes okay fine so according to the
Quran that comes 600 years later um it
makes a claim about Jesus somebody who
existed you know 600 years prior so it's
a claim on a historical figure so what
you have to do is you have to provide
historical evidence that the claim that
the Quran makes about Jesus is
true okay yeah can you clarify for me
that the Pharisees um seek Jesus's death
according to Christian history because
he claimed to be the king of the Jews or
because he claimed to be
God what does it have to do with my what
we're talking
about well here's the thing right it
would be a much bigger
violation uh surely if he was to claimed
to be uh uh if he was claimed to be God
right but what does that have to do with
the question
here well your entire argument
presupposes the fact that you know Jesus
was claiming to be embodying God which
would go against the Islamic principles
right I don't CLA which is what we well
I I I don't claim that he ided God I
believe he is God but and that he said
that he was God but my belief doesn't
matter here my my belief doesn't matter
I'm asking for the evidence historically
that Jesus believed lined up with and
practice
Islam well yeah obviously we get into
this problem don't we we have to use
your
sources and that's the problem isn't it
is that the historic that's what that's
the that's the only sources you'll trust
that's the only that's the only sources
that's trustworthy the only sources that
are trustworthy on the life of Jesus are
the you know I wouldn't say the only
sources that are trustworthy per se I
would say the primary sources that are
trustworthy on the life of Jesus is the
New Testament it's those are the
historical sources that we use yeah
okay so you expect me to
believe that uh our understanding of
Jesus being Muslim is incorrect because
your early text your Bible everything
you
have goes against Islamic fundamentals
everything we everything we know about
Jesus
historically contradicts
Islam okay which Islamic fundamentals or
being aspects of being a Muslim does it
contradict well see that you're trying
to switch the question what you have to
show me is that Jesus lined up with the
core doctrines of Islam and didn't
contradict them that's what you that's
what I'm asking for the proof of and
then when you show me these these
evidences we'll look at that and see if
it
holds okay if I use your sources is that
a problem for you it's I think that
that's what you should be using so
please by all means okay he states that
he was sent by the by by God to conduct
his will correct where does he say that
what's the what's the verse or um he was
sent down by the father correct sent by
the father in John that's right he does
say he was sent by the
father okay is Allah his father that's
an aspect of prophethood that's an
aspect of following a singular entity
called God is is is Allah is Allah his
father no is so that's a core doctrine
that goes against Islam
right we don't yeah it says explicitly
that we do not call God the Father
exactly so then I'm giving you I'm
giving you I'm giving you the closest
examples according to your sources of an
instance of Prophecy or prophethood in
which a prophet is sent to spread a
message and has been endowed with this
message by a singular all powerful
entity but but notice this though no
notice how the the closest thing you can
get to is something that contradicts the
core doctrine of Islam that Allah is not
a father and he has no children because
I'm using your sources they br yeah so
according to the sources that we have it
shows that Jesus is the opposite of a
Muslim then right yeah your your sources
are objectively false even not
considering Islam okay so you by P by by
by pure logic Alone come on you expect
me to believe those Jews in that region
in the Middle East all began to serve
the rabbi and were willing to be put to
death for the rabbi a guy who was
walking around claiming to be the Son of
God and literally God incarnate I mean
come on stop taking the piss Avery come
on I don't think I don't think that
Scott Scott I got I gotta stop you there
okay that none of this helps okay what
we have seen so far that based on the
evidence based on the primary source
Jesus is not a Muslim because he says
that he God is his Father which goes
directly against the core of Islam Allah
not being a father to anyone I've
already explain to you this like every
one of the topics you debate this is why
you don't debate in Earnest with all due
respect this is why I don't debate what
you don't debate in Earnest with
sincerity because all the topics because
all the topics you pick are ones where
the fundamentals of the topic are so
dtic between the two faiths that there
is no there's no synergy let's so let's
so let's debate let's debate in Earnest
together let's debate honestly and in
Earnest together sh give me give me the
proof give me a reliable source okay
historically that demonstrates that
Jesus indeed lined up with core Islamic
Doctrine you want me to use your
biblical sources to prove that Jesus was
a Muslim use whatever is historically
reliable man historically reliable on
the life of Jesus Jesus where we get
information about Jesus use that to show
me that Jesus was a
Muslim the only historical records of
Jesus Christ come from either the Bible
or second on accounts from uh Roman and
otherwise historians from that era
around around a say that one more
time your sound your sound started a
little distorted you said the only only
sources we have in the life of Jesus is
what again what was the first thing you
mentioned from the fir from the from the
first two centuries the sources that we
have are the New Testament and and the
and the secondhand histo historian
accounts from from the likes of tus
Josephus Etc which again are only
recorded several centuries afterwards
but yeah those are the first two Century
accounts and then the other are the ones
we have in Islam which is the Quran all
right so the so so the historical
sources hold hold up hold Scott Scott
Scott you're cooking right now man
you're doing good so the source the
historical sources that we have on the
life of Jesus are one is number one the
New Testament documents that's the
earliest that we have secondly are the
secondary sources by you know Roman
historians you know Joseph is tacitus
finding the younger other people like
this and
then third
you know you just have like what comes
like hundreds of years after that would
which would be Islamic sources the Quran
right which by the way your your um
inability to accept the quranic source
as valid I find to be um not entirely
objectively reasonable because let me
tell can I tell you why and I'm not
speaking here even from an Islamic
perspective you are though just from
you're speaking from an Islamic
perspective Scott no no no no it's
actually not reasonable because it was
recited in the latter half of the sixth
and early half of the 7th century and
there were Christians in that time who
had been following through oral
tradition for centuries the original
Christian belief so to say that these
are not legitimate Source legitimate
sources is quite ridiculous to be honest
wait wait wait wait wait wait stop
you're saying that Christians in 7th
Century Arabia had true Christianity
and they had sources where they had true
Christianity um and you're saying that
I'm denying those sources that they
had well you're denying that a document
in the seventh century could be valid no
is what you're denying no I'm not no I'm
not you did say that ear Scott let me be
clear let me be clear okay let me be
clear I am not saying that a sth century
document is automatically invalid that's
not what I'm saying I'm saying that a
sth c Century document
is not the
authority on the historicity of
something that came 700 years prior when
you have evidence to the contrary that's
earlier that's uh vastly attested you
know independent sources so when you
have you already have things that are
early um have multiple attestation
independent sources they already passed
the historic criteria
so a 7th Century document it can be
valid as long as it lines up with the
historical sources that come before if
it contradicts them then it is something
that is ahistorical meaning it goes
against
history did Jesus submit his will to God
which God what you call God the Father
God the Father yes he submitted to his
father and is the definition of a Muslim
one who submits his will to God to Allah
specifically of the Quran who's not a
father now you're now you're placing an
extra differentiator which is to claim
that our God and your God are different
which we both know is not the case well
we're using logic right you said we got
to use logic so let's use it we got to
use your logic logic if if Allah says
like for example look look look if I say
I'm a Muslim um and the God that I
submit to is my statute is that Allah is
the god that I'm serving
Allah of course not and we both and but
of course not no I hope you're not a
Catholic and you believe that's okay
okay no slander in the Catholics please
so look so even though I say that I'm
worshiping God I'm submitting to God as
a Muslim but the god that I'm talking
about is a statute I have in my closet
you said no that's not Allah why why is
the statute that I'm talking about that
I call God that I say is the one creator
of the universe verse why are you saying
that that's not
Allah it goes against the Ten
Commandments
where thou shalt not make graven images
but wait hold on hold on a second if
you're talking about the Ten
Commandments that has nothing to do with
Allah that's Yahweh I'm talking about
Allah doesn't matter that principle
Islam No you don't why do you say that
the statute that I'm worshiping that I'm
submitting to and I call God the one God
who created all things that that is not
Allah so hang on a second are you saying
now that what you define as God I need
you to answer my question my
brother so apologies repeat the question
how why are you saying that the statute
that I'm worshiping that I say is the
one God who I submit to why do you say
that that's not
Allah that's not how we Define Allah
very good so because you define Allah in
a specific way anything that goes out
out of that definition is not Allah
right correct good so when you define
Allah is father one of the ways that you
define
Allah no very good so if Jesus is
praying to his God who he says is his
father that's not how you define Allah
so therefore he's not talking about
Allah that's not Allah who he's
submitting to yes yes but you've
conflicted two things so what your words
I conflated your words together it's not
that it's not that in this instance it
is a separate it is a separate
identifier entity it's simply a matter
of confusion on your on your side okay
so when I'm worshiping my statute we'll
go back to this again I'm worshiping
aitt to my stat let me this let me this
hang on let me this man this perfect if
I submit to my statue right this Idol
this statue that I say is God who
created all things it's not really that
it's not Allah it's just that I'm
confused about Allah is that
right yes so the statute is I I am
referring I it is Allah but I'm
just wait wait no not the statue let me
give you a better example what do you
mean better let me let me let me let me
let me give you a better example this is
perfect let's say let let let's say you
and I are standing in a field and
there's a single tree in the field okay
and I point to this tree and I say this
is
ZaZa and you point to the tree and say
this is blah blah and I say you and I
are both pointing to ZaZa and you say no
we're both pointing to blah blah we're
both pointing at the same thing we're
just calling it different
things nice okay so you call God the
Father which you're mistaken about it's
actually called Zaza okay okay and we
don't call it father we're talking about
the same thing right and if I identify
Allah if I identify Allah as the statue
wait excuse me if I identify Allah as my
statute are we talking about the same
thing no because we're not pointing at
we're not talking about the same top
topic right we are we're talking about
God I'm saying God is the statue are we
talking about the same thing do you
believe God is a statue in this example
and are we talking about the same thing
no no no Scott Scott please keep up man
I want to I want want to keep you here
so I'm keeping up with you but the
example you're using is is fous I've
shown you why it's fous you're not
showing me why it's fous I'm I went I
went exactly with what you're saying so
if I'm referring to my statute as God
you're say you're referring to something
as God that's invisible it's not a
statute I'm referring to my physical
statute as God are we referring to the
same thing let's but no but can we
please talk about what we actually yes
but can we stick to what we actually
both believe God to
be you and I both agree that God is
creator of all things
right yes good so I believe that God is
the creator of all things there's no
partner to him
right correct okay cool I say that about
my statute my statute is the creator of
all things but you don't stop stop my
statute is the creator of all things my
statute has no partner is that
Allah no so we're talking about two
different things because Allah is
defined in a specific way and he has a
specific nature and characteristic while
my statute does not fit that definition
right yes I I Avery please give me one
moment I understand the argument you're
making but the reason it's felicious is
because the statue example is not what
you actually as a Christian believe you
don't actually believe a statute to hold
these talking about Christians we're
talking about your definition
I understand I understand what you're
attempting to do but it's fous you're
still not telling me how
it's what would be what would I'm
explaining it to you what would be
better here is if we both established
what we believe God to be we already did
that we already did that so if I already
I already stop stop stop stop stop stop
because you running from this example
doesn't help you you see the problem you
see the problem SC don't cut me off
right now please so if you say that you
see the point that I'm making then you
see the problem stop saying oh well
we're you know let's actually talk to
you as a Christian you don't believe the
CH statute is a is is Allah it doesn't
matter if I'm a Christian if I'm a pagan
idolator it doesn't matter if my
definition of God if my concept of God
does not match the definition of Allah
in Islam then I'm not talking about
Allah does that make
sense of course okay does does the does
the definition of Allah fit father yes
or no
not father no so then if I'm saying that
the God that I submit to is my father am
I talking about
Allah you have a mistaken understanding
of Allah am I talking about Allah it's a
yes or
no we could be talking about the same
thing but you have a mistaken def
attribute which is the father so so I
can so again if I'm with the statute I
could just be mistaken about Allah by
attributing him to a statue I am I'm
talking about Allah but you know I'm
just wrong that he's a statue is that
correct if if if if you hold all other
attributes except uh you were to point
to his stat you'd be mistaken about
saying he has some kind of physical
capacity or you can can be measured as a
statue yeah got it so just to be clear
if I say that my statue hold on if I say
to my statute is the creator of all
things is the maker of all things has no
partner I'm still talking about Allah
but I'm just wrong to attribute him to
being a statute I'm still talking about
Allah but sir certain attributes are
different to others so for example if
you describe something as if you father
is a descriptive word it's an
identity yeah it's an identity so it's
not the same as saying something as a
statue forance the one it's the same let
me tell you why it's the same because
like you said earlier we don't Define a
that way so that's not Allah so it
matters do you define Allah as father no
so if you're saying that God is Father
it's not Allah it's that simp hang on a
second hang on a second I give you the
example of the tree let me give you
another example because you didn't
understand my example no I understood I
understood your example if I if I SC
Scott Scott Scott I understand your
example for example I know you as Scott
um your mom knows you as son so if she
says my son is on Tik Tok and I say
Scott's on Tik Tok we're talking about
the same person just referring to you as
a different different name different
title same person though right boom okay
so I TR trust me I understand your
example and hopefully it sound like you
understood mine but you don't want to
conclude with what the problem is you
cannot say that if I'm saying that a
statute is God then I'm talking about
Allah you was you said that yeah that's
not a lot in the beginning but now
you're struggling now to say that oh
well y either it's not Allah outright or
that I'm just wrong about Allah so which
one is it if when I'm saying that my
statute is God is is that really Allah
that I'm talking about but I'm just
wrong about him or is this is this just
not Allah at all which one is
it the issue is there's a fundamental
theological issue here okay you're
looking for there to be a one toone 100%
100% relationship between the attributes
you define in Christian text with the
Islam which one is it which one is it
when I say that I submit to my statute
who created all things is that Allah or
is it or am I just wrong about
Allah my my belief is that we both refer
to the same being however on the
attribute of the father that is a
mistake on on on your part that's not
what I asked you when I say I submit to
my
statute am I talking about Allah or am I
just wrong about about
Allah uh are you talking about Allah or
are you wrong about Allah no you're
wrong you're wrong you're wrong it's a
different it's a different it's a
different scale rather than saying
father it's a different skill all right
so let so let me go with you let me go
with you on this you're attributing
you're you're attributing human
qualities to God right so we're just so
we're wrong we're wrong about Allah when
we say God is a statue we're wrong about
Allah Okay cool so now let's go with
that so if if we say that God is a
father then we're wrong about Allah
right correct we're wrong about God
we're wrong about Allah okay so when
Jesus said that God is his father was he
wrong about
Allah I don't believe he said that you
you cot it the Bible was he wrong about
Allah in the Bible yeah this is the
problem we come into this is the problem
we face it's problem we face got it so
Jesus was wrong about Allah is that
correct
uh I don't believe Jesus was wrong about
anything personally except then then
Allah is his father
then but but I don't believe he said uh
he was his father either okay how did
Jesus pray tell me what do you
think there is no single instance where
it elucidates very clearly how Jesus
prayed in detail in the biblical text
really he said please please you said
please you said in the you said in you
said in the biblical text there's no
detailed example of excuse me of how
Jesus
prayed yes step by step what about in
the Quran is there a detailed
explanation of how Jesus prayed besides
obviously we obviously we have Matthew
Etc but I'm talking so there is an
example of how Jesus prayed nice how did
he
pray yeah but you understand what I mean
when I say like a detail step by step
you know every motion how did how did he
pray man that's all I want to know how
did he pray
um uh I think I believe he played he
prayed similarly to uh well there are
multiple maners in which he prayed let
me let me ask you this if you wanted to
know how Jesus prayed wait wait wait let
me let me let me let me just ask you
this Scott if you wanted to know how
Jesus prayed where would you go to find
that
out what do you mean you mean is a
Muslim or is a Christian
as a Muslim uh we believe he prayed in
accordance with how we've always
prayed which I believe is accounted for
in the in the Bible as well but again in
the Bible it's there's multiple matters
in which he
prays there there Scott Scott stop
talking Scott Scott Scott stop talking
please if you wanted to know how Jesus
prayed where would you
go as a what as a a Muslim or is a
Christian
period you know what let's do it this
way as a Muslim show me how Jesus prayed
go
ahead what as as a Muslim show me the
reference that shows you how Jesus
prayed um I I don't recall in thean the
exact reference
to pring so you don't have this
information in the Quran okay so if you
wanted to know how Jesus prayed or thei
if you wanted to know how Jesus prayed
where would you go you don't have it in
the Quran or Hadith so where would you
go um I mean if if I wanted a Christian
understanding of how we prayed I would I
would look no just just how would you
where would you go period if you just
want to you just man you know what I
wonder how Jesus prayed peace be upon
Him may his peace be upon me I want to
know how he prayed where would you
go what do you mean I look at the
biblical text there you go
you would go to the Bible and when you
go to the Bible and you see how Jesus
prayed how did he
pray like I said I I don't remember
exactly but I believe there are multiple
maners in which he prayed you're right
there are multiple manners in how he
prayed you're absolutely right and in
each of these examples however there's
one thing that's consistent what do you
think that
is the the reference to the Father the
reference to his father so when we look
historically and the only source in all
of humanity that we have on how Jesus
prayed we have the New Testament that
tells us and every time we see Jesus
praying the one who he's praying to is
his father in
Heaven so
historically is Jesus a
Muslim what that's
corrupted thanks for coming Scott
wait wait wait don't draw me this yet I
do I got I got I got other guest man
this I I have other guest who cares
about the other guest I do I do man I
look next time I'll let you host you can
let up whoever you want
okay okay sure all right why not but by
the way prove Jes prove Jesus was a
Christian and I'll give you $10,000 okay
all right next time all right take care
Scott love you brother take care byebye